the west bank had uh had changed
completely in this
20 years in terms of numbers of settlers
in terms of areas which settlers are de
facto controlling
this is the settlement of modern elite
which was established
20 less than 25 years ago right yeah and
since van is growing and today
its population is around 70 000
people and for people to understand
settlement
and outpost what's the difference well
the usually someone refers to uh
israeli uh israeli settlements which are
officially approved
by the israeli government and the
israeli outposts
are israeli settlements which had been
built also by the israeli government but
without officially approved
both settlements those type of
settlements are actually
out there in order to achieve the same
goal which is to julia's growing part of
west bank so how would you describe that
policy
apartheid
so what do we see on that hill over
there this is one out of
around 40 new herding outposts which
were established in the last
decade in the west bank what's a hurting
outpost hurrying up has meaning that
one family perhaps a few youngsters
are is coming and is basically taking
over
huge area palestinians who cross certain
in a certain point you can see the
valley down there if you start going up
you are exposed immediately to massive
island or settler
everything is backed by the military of
course the military is protects them
major protect them all the time and
you've been doing this for you said
almost two decades
is this has this increased actually
during the trump administration years
okay these are the years where the
crucial years in terms of
geographical expansion sevis road is
going to be a new access road
this is a new access road to us to a new
part of the summit
right now this settlement of
they are they have been united
palestinians of course
of course i mean no one else does this
work these are very young people and
they don't get permitted to work in
israel
so the bigger picture in terms of what
you've observed what you've
documented settlement expansion over
time how would you describe it well what
we've seen the last years is
one of the one of the biggest boons
in terms of construction in west bank we
haven't seen so much construction
happening it's actually since i started
monitoring
we're not talking only about
construction and settlement we're
talking about
very very expensive and heavy
infrastructure
projects which are being built in the
west bank in the last years which we
haven't seen for
we haven't seen being built for for
decades since actually oslo
the prison infrastructure had been
exhausted in order to
bring hundreds of thousands of new
settlers into the israeli southernmost
bank they need to have to expand their
infrastructure we need more water they
need more roads
we need more more telecommunication
infrastructure
so a palestinian state
which state there's nobody in states
the land has been milan is gone
israel made sure of it we know it's
ready no palestinian state and what's
been
the story the story is over